her voice was compared to many things
even an angel
but it was her extraordinary rendition
of the Girl from Ipanema that made the
song and the Brazilian musical genre
Bossa Nova famous worldwide
Gilberto was born in Brazil to a German
father and Brazilian mother she was only
22 when she married musician Xiao
Gilberto and although she had never
studied singing her rendition of the
song became an immediate hit
it won her four Grammys the song was
originally recorded a year earlier in
1962 by its authors vinicius de morais
and Tom Jobim
it was inspired by a 15 year old girl
whom they would see passing on her way
to Rio de Janeiro's Ipanema Beach
but it was Astro gilberto's voice and
version of the song in English that made
the Girl from Ipanema one of the things
most identified with Brazil not
surprisingly it was played at the
opening ceremony of the 2016 Rio
Olympics
[Music]
went on to sing other famous songs such
as corcovado and The Shadow of Your
Smile and recorded 19 albums in 2002 she
was added to the international Latin
music hall of fame a well-deserved honor
for a singer who received relatively
little attention in her country of birth
but who helped more than anyone put
Bossa Nova on the global stage she died
at the age of 83.